you know what shawn so this is yeah you
go to hell
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today i'm joined by keegan michael key
jordan peel together their key and peel
and they star in keanu in theaters april
29th a film that explores the age-old
question how far is a man willing to go
to save his adorable kitty cat it's a
question that's been asked
for millennia very funny i saw it last
night the first spit take of my adult
life actually i had a you have a good
film the first one the first spit take
of my adult life
don't want to miss quote but i was
taking a very very usual suspect i was
taking a very deep sip of sprite
swinging white noise
wordness to the turdness oh my god
and unbelievable right back in the right
end of the cup this is a text i sent uh
keegan a couple of years ago and then we
had the potential i can't remember i
wish i could remember what the context
of it was
to determine all right you guys ready
ready
[Music]
so we have double the talent half as
many wings this time overnight first
wings
special treats hot ones firey chipotle
it's actually our sauce this is your
sauce made by homeboys distributed by
heatness you can find it online already
mouth is watering
thank you one of the things that kind of
stands out to me in the movie is method
man's performance yeah and that guy has
a ton of roles over the years and many
of them are comedic roles which kind of
flies in the face of what i think a lot
of people think of when they think of
method man he's very um he's very much a
real guy he has the same problems that
any of us have
he just sounds a lot cooler when he
talks about them he literally was pacing
on set one day completely frustrated
yeah
because
the principal is these two kids are the
same age uh which were commonly known as
twins um
they had the graduation and he was
getting very upset because he was going
this ridiculous man
superintendent i'm gonna tell me i'm
gonna get three tickets
i should get six [ __ ] tickets this is
ridiculous man i got two children how's
my auntie supposed to see my my babies i
mean they helped raise my kids
so they go to mathematics and everything
that's some stupid [ __ ] i gotta make a
phone call i mean it's like mundane
school stuff he never rapped about this
never rapped about this josh and it's
kind of funny to see a guy like method
man have just everyday normal people oh
my god right yeah he has to
wake up one shoe at a time like the rest
of us doesn't wake up yeah he wakes up
one shoe at a time that's a saying
people say that every day someone said
that this morning this guy back here
said it i guarantee it
all right you ready for number two
hot ones that's a nice sauce this is
where it we're going up a little bit
we're going on 100 yep [ __ ]
keegan my guess is that you've been
asked about
luther obama's pain obama's anger
translator that was also obama's
pain translator emotional pain yes yes
emotional pain anger translator and
you've probably been asked about it in
every interview since that white house
correspondents dinner hold on to your
lilly white butts
what's your most treasured memory from
that night remote
the most treasured memory for me this is
not
a joke a joke
i'm about to also not tell a joke 100
height of his hand
how's the pain what's the honey with him
no no you know you know 99
well here's the thing you're sorry you
got this is the second one only two
we still got three to go
we were talking we were talking about we
were talking the big game
oh
no that's crazy he
he was uh i was present that that was
the most that was the most precious
thing i wasn't freaking out i wasn't
having an autobiography experience but
having the ability to touch him and he
was perfectly cool at that when we
rehearsed it which was that was awesome
being able to touch him
and also i guess the best one would have
been with uh michelle
michelle you're right brother you okay
were you a little nervous about touching
him for the first time do you think like
security like secret service would
change oh wow oh my god well he runs
into the room and runs up to me and he
bro hugs me and i'm like let me i'm not
doing it i'm not doing it take please
you can feel like a red dot on your
forehead like he grabs that's a problem
i think anybody gets good because he's
just up there hugging just just grabbing
phones people
he loves to be hugging joints yeah
j-o-i-n-k-s joint joint joints
you don't speak at ease that's why you
may hit me
he be hugging joints tell him a joint
because hey any person that comes in uh
to a room
that it just looks huggable you know so
he'd be like he'd be hugging joints no
don't be drinking water i didn't do it
you saw me say i was gonna do it but i
didn't do it right you saw i didn't do
it i'm not a [ __ ] [ __ ]
there is one in our movie there's
actually one in our there is an adorable
kitty all right ready for this this is
my swearing so much it says wings it's a
youtube show and uh you can swear if you
want i like the [ __ ] truth of that
this is the bomb beyond insanity okay
and the names are getting longer and
more complicated yeah and that's no
that's the radiation symbol that's
that's what they put on it when you're
not supposed to be near it in the same
room with it
so i might walk out of here with a 30
year or something
straight chernobyl you know that
chernobyl happened on my actual birth
date april 26 1986. oh that's what i
watched
yeah i was born there that's why you can
eat all these places
that's why you don't have any problem
with these at all it's a little
unsettling how these aren't bothering
you at all yeah what's up with that i've
done it a bunch of times this is not a
new experience for me joints my joints
right here
sean let's just be honest for a moment
you put
battery acid in here that's no joke that
one's not a fun one dude this is not fun
you know one of the oh no oh you went
for the milk
i'm not too proud i know like what this
is no no no no i know what i'm not you
don't get all you don't get away out of
the milk question
i'm not no [ __ ] i know what this is just
give me a mulligan on the one milk i'll
give you a all again if you now you
stick with this
gun oh my god
oh yeah american god damn it
you know one of the sad things about key
and peel coming to an end is that there
are these great we're dying we had to do
this
we're these recurring characters that
were so amazing but we kind of don't
know what happened to some of them in
the past year plus so i'm hoping i i can
just bounce them off of you and you're
awesome yeah i'm gonna tell you right
now i'll give you the first one
andre snaps megan come back to the bar
andre snapped yeah he cuts megan into
[ __ ] 75 little pieces and sticks her
in a suitcase and jumps around the river
this is going to happen
relationships
yeah
uh what about uh wendell sanders uh guys
we're gonna want another pizza let me
just who's hungry show her hands his pee
started burning
his pee started his beans god damn it
are we i'm i'm that's in here i'm
hallucinating right now there's an mma
it's a ufc match
right here in this sinus you got a
little bit of something
i don't know
how's that nfl career going you know
what
i made the last two
well give us a sec
get this out of here this is done i
finished that
mid last two uh
53 and rosters
uh but he's not playing yet that's the
issue he had that one banner game
then he went dancing the night after
that
and tore a uh
come on man come on don't touch it come
on sean don't touch it 357 mad dog
come on man that's that's that's like a
gun that's
this sauce will blow you away
357 000 scoville oh come on man
stop and that's our second
hottest one do you want to explain to
the crowd
357 000
i'm amazed that you know what a 357 000
scoville is here's what i know i know
that it's a unit
i'll tell you i know it has something to
do with how [ __ ] up my mouth feels
i'll tell you
my unit is not going to be working
anymore after this better it'll be
working better it'll be working better
you think that yes yes
you ready for mad dog 357 of course no
no let's go this is why we're here all
right well we're here dude you're hungry
there's some sweetness in there but it's
gonna it's gonna rape us in the ass
isn't it yeah
it's time
that's a trojan part release a trojan
horse with that sweetness
that's that's a
genghis khan just rode through my
conceals
what's going on here whoo
top seals oh my gosh that's that's
so i'm fascinated by the idea of camping
awesome camp awesome and all these
sketches that don't see the light of the
day
isn't that the purgatory that you guys
put the sketches that don't make them
out of the light
the deepest most referential [ __ ] we
can't remember that we're blind but that
is correct sure
so sean i'm having a stroke and you're
going for more bites that's admirable
you gotta keep up
you already gave up my brother
what are you most upset about not seeing
the light of day there has to be
something in that can that's waterproof
you'll see
water sketch the water sketch disgust
where we're just in a battle water
oh just bring that sketch
we are swimming and drowning happily
what was the question
what sketch in camp awesome are you so
upset that it just hasn't seen the light
of day that nobody will ever see it
there's got to be something in that can
that you're like damn it that can nobody
wants did he send the water sketch yeah
there's this milk sketch in that uh oh
mix it up
no scratches
looks like this is the one for me
all right you guys ready to do this last
one last one you know what sean so this
is yeah you go to hell
i want you to look at the consistency of
this now so this is don't touch it with
your bare hands it's kind of traditional
give me just a second take a walk take a
lap to dab last one dab it let me dab
the lid grab your own
ass off man dab your own ass and then
you guys you know what if you don't
whose [ __ ] idea was this show
you don't want it you don't have to
that's a big dab
are you do you have like a
unrealistic chernobyl he's got one of
those things
your whole inside is made out of like
some kind of synthetic because yeah like
i'm uh like it's not fair
yeah the inside of your body is made out
of asbestos it's like remembering the
princess bride when the guy had like
built up the immunity to the [ __ ]
poison that's where i'm at that's you
you're the dreaded private robber okay
what what happened to this whole thing
and then people are you at all impressed
with this or is it just it just seems
like a a type of madness like maybe i
should go get something checked out it
seems like you figured out something you
can do and you built a whole show around
it
that's what it seems like isn't that
what we did oh yeah
more power to you oh you go to hell sean
all right so for this last wing if you
don't want to dab you don't have to dab
some people are going to die why are you
going to bring up dabbing man i'm going
to i'm going to dab
you got to dab you got to
you're not gonna dab so and then this
last question i'm gonna bring it full
circle i'm going from the second city
main stage god from key and people this
guy's got the deep cuts all the way to
keanu okay
so there's a little dab my favorite
characters ever were the valets but did
you see that liam nieces movie with them
wolves though the one with them big ass
wolves and liam nieces
is my [ __ ]
and they probably would have been so
hyped to see keanu so for this last one
let's all take a bite yep and we'll all
die
and then i want to sort of re-imagine no
don't doubt that much
how the
how the valets would talk about keanu
after seeing it does that sound like a
good plan oh you dabbed out
all right
cheers i'm just trying to spread this
dab out dab it out that's a sick dab dab
step so
i don't like the way he did it
i don't like the way he did it all fast
she was scared
yo you see that
you're sweating you see that key in
people's movies
that movie was fine
that movie was fire i don't even know
what i'm about to say the dog
movie yeah i'll give that movie five
volcanoes yo that movie was a fireball
in my eye
now i'm moving and they have neil
longsies in there
and the mh od males yup yup yup they got
uh willie forts in there
i'm speechless
cause i don't got no vocal cords left
you remember that part at the end of the
sketch where we blow up yeah let's do
that right now
yeah you made it all the way through
hot ones it's so high stakes i know we
put you guys through a lot
but at the end 30 second plug how
amazing is that 30 seconds we have to
stay alive for 30 seconds floor is yours
tell the people what they should see
well if you're watching this show
don't ever come on the show
don't come on it don't make don't get
into the film industry because you might
end up on youtube
do go see keanu on april 29th
don't order the wings
just keep your feet planted on the
ground i keep reaching for the stars
yeah what whatever arrives with ass
kicked chris compact trick i need these
and i need these yeah i get salad from
burger king
i'm not [ __ ] with you now man
like yo these dudes are doing something
different and dad would totally have sex
with you
if you wore those all right i need these
in 11.
now